[Music]
hey what's going on guys the cat is out
the bag the god logic shirts are out
click the link in the description and
head on over to God logic.com to
purchase our first release we just read
let's go I'll see you guys with a shirt
peace yeah so if so your your your
contentions are the history of
Christianity how stuff came about um and
so as far as like with Islam cuz I like
to talk to people where they are you
know I don't want to like you know come
at you with stuff that you don't know or
something like that but just
particularly your own conviction on why
Islam is true to you you know and then
we can I guess go from there yeah yeah
we can do that yeah so what would you
say is your is the best reason why you
you say Islam is true what conv number
one reason would be the Quran itself
yeah the crown itself I say the
preservation of it um see manuscript uh
evidence of it of not it only being um
preserved orally but also through
manuscripts
um not only that but um I guess this
isn't evidence right but I feel like
everybody can kind of uh tie this in you
know I'm not going to talk about that
I'm not talk about that because it's
personal person yeah yeah yeah I'm not
going to tie that in because I I'd
rather be more evidence-based you know
okay so more
objective objectively you're saying the
Quran um it's preservation and that's
what so what do you mean but when you
say preservation cuz everybody kind of
has a different view like obviously with
Christians our view of preservation is
as long as the message um and theology
is consistent in the manuscripts were
good even if there's textual variance
for you what what do you mean by
preservation yeah I would say everything
that you said but without the textual
textual VAR so no textual variance word
for word letter for letter the same yeah
not just the manuscripts but also how
it's memorized okay all right okay cool
so we we could work with that so have
you looked into that in in in depth I
haven't looked it as deep as I have in
Christianity but I have looked into okay
so because again my special specialty is
more in Christianity yeah um in Islam
obviously I know enough to the point
where I converted but not obviously it's
been one year as a as a Muslim four
years as a Christian is a lot more time
so yeah AB you're absolutely right so
then so have you heard of uh the
different um Arabic versions of the
Quran like War
I've heard of this claim but I haven't
looked into it okay so so what what what
it what it is is they'll say that they
they're called and forgive my
pronunciation but Kat that's what they
they call it right they'll say it's
different modes of recitation right
however so however so you have like
you'll have like seven canonical
readings right these are the standard
readings that are really authoritative
you have hofs coloon warsh
duri casai and Alam all right now
there's there's others but these are
like the main seven okay and um for the
I I I would say to be gracious for the
most part they're the same for the most
part they're the same however they do
have textual variance in them and they
have textual variants where there are
some that change the meaning like the
context of the verse would change
depending on what you do like here's one
that I bring about if you scene but I
brought it up to shik man before or it's
like it's the easiest one that I know
but um there's one and so in the in the
HS Quran or which is the normal Quran
that most people use and chapter 37:2
it'll say um um where Allah speak to
Muhammad that you were surprised when
the disbelievers mocked right you
wondered why they mocked right in the
Hamza version of the Quran and these are
all Arabic it's not English it's Arabic
yeah it's Allah saying I was surprised
while they mocked I wondered right now
some will say well that you know that's
not a contradiction you know um you know
Muhammad was surprised while they mocked
Allah was you know wondering or
surprised not in a sense that he doesn't
know but just it's figure of speech or
whatever right which is cool I don't
mind however they interpret that however
that changes right you have Muhammad
who's the one who's being surprised then
Allah's the one that changes the meaning
of the entire context right so you have
these type of differences in there now I
know you said you would haven't looked
into that but yeah I mean more than
happy to look into and then get back to
as soon as I can so that's not an issue
you know any claim people want to bring
to me I'm more than willing to look at
it the same way that you know people
will tell me like I'm closed-minded it's
like I was open-minded to the point
where I changed my entire religion that
I practiced for 4 years you know and I I
if you watch thank you bro and if you
watch the video too of when when me and
spoke to each other he got himself a I
know right he toilet
water it always T like that what is this
this is great you want some you good man
yeah I'm telling
you n I'm okay thank you bro yeah I'm
good we're all right thanks man but
basically like um when when me and him
spoke I kind of I kind of talked about
that about how like I KN I wasn't born
into the religion so you know my parents
are Mexican and they're uh Catholic just
by title because that's that's you know
the culture yeah but don't take it
serious and so I found it on my own when
I was 19 and I ended up accepting
Christianity when I was 19 all the way
up till I was um 23 uh 22 sorry um 18 to
22 and so um or like right before I
turned 19 and so anyway um yeah I'm I'm
more than happy to look into whatever
you bring to me good okay I want to give
you some some sources some references
we'll use our phones and stuff like that
so if you go on your phone do you um
there's a there's a website it's called
sun.com oh yeah with that okay good
perfect that's where I get all the
Hadith from and
so cuz if we're talking about
preservation of the Quran in the sense
that hasn't no letter no dot everything
exactly the same bro I'm telling you
right now there's so much stuff when it
comes to the Quran that shows that there
were variants and that even people
disagreed on you know certain readings
and whatever I'll show you I'll just
show you this so one I'll show you that
Aisha talks about some verses that were
in the
Quran and they're not in the Quran today
okay so um if you go to sun.com well
I'll pull it up to myself so let me see
um 10 clear
sucklings
okay all
right
okay so here's the Hadith so it's sahim
Muslim MH 1452 a okay it says Aisha
Allah be pleased with her reported that
it had been revealed in the Holy Quran
10 clear sucklings that make the
marriage unlawful then it was abrogated
and substituted by five CL by five
sucklings and Allah's Apostle may peace
be upon Him died and it was before that
time found in the Holy Quran and recited
by the Muslims so you're familiar with
the with agregation what that is not
really okay so in the Quran it says this
um in chapter 2 verse is that
106 life abrogation is it 2 106 I
believe so I think it's 106 we do not
abgate a verse or cause it to be
forgotten except that we bring forth one
better than it or similar to it do you
not know that Allah is over all things
competent so what it's saying is is that
you know verses don't get forgotten or
deleted it's just that Allah replaces it
with something that's similar to it or
something that's better than it all
right and so when it says here that so
at first there were 10 clear sucklings
that make a marriage unlawful in the in
the Quran it got arreated to five so it
got changed to five right but then and
then at that time by when Muhammad died
it was in the Quran they used to read it
in everything it's not in the Quran
today M right and there so you have
examples like like this where it talks
about what used to be in the Quran in
their time what they used to read and
stuff like that and it doesn't exist
today and no Quran that you pick up it
doesn't exist it's not even anyone's
oral transmission you know yeah well
again yeah I mean I'll look into this
you know I want to I want to look at
everything from both angles you know
what I mean and get an answer as soon as
I get an answer you know whether it's an
answer that I like or don't like I'll
let you know you for sure yeah I can't
wait to hear yeah I'm here to yeah so
don't um yeah I want want you to to
remember this so if we uh he has your
number and everything yeah he okay
perfect so I'll send you the Hadi to
give to him so he can take it to he a
mom or ask people about it or how he
does his research okay
so so in light of this let me let me ask
you this if you found that the Quran did
have these textual variants that yes
indeed these were the the qurans did
have variant in them what would that
mean for you as a Muslim and to your
faith then so if I had a texal in the
manuscripts that
would that would not shake my faith too
much the reason why is because again the
Quran was revealed as oral tradition
right okay so if it's revealed through a
oral tradition and it's the same that it
was 1400 years ago today then that's
that's the preservation that we're
talking about if it's on a manuscript
and there's let's say variations then
well again that's a manuscript um what
the word like that's a that's a that's a
like a Scrabble error right yeah okay so
that does really have any any impact on
the Quran that let's say the H that
recites the Quran in Saudi Arabia
recites here in Vegas there's no
difference between it well then all
right so all right so now let me ask you
this then what if someone's oral
tradition is different than someone's
someone else's if you found that even in
the oral tradition how people are
reciting the Quran and how they think it
goes all the way back that there's some
differences there what would that mean
for you then well go to what the
majority of people are reciting are
going with okay got you okay so even if
there's a even if there's variation in
the in the oral recitation whatever I
guess the majority is you'll you'll lean
towards that and that doesn't really
change your faith as a Muslim you'll
still believe in the Quran it doesn't
really okay cool would shake my faith
much cool okay so then so then I would
say then after this that the
preservation of the Quran as you first
saw ver first heard it I don't think is
um I guess the the the rock of your
faith in Islam because if it wasn't
preserved as you previously thought it
was you still believe in it well no no
no it's not that it's not preserved
correctly it's the fact that if well
kind of like I just said said right now
um let's say let's say a group a whole
group of a let's say this different sect
of Islam came and they said this is how
we recite the Quran and it's different
from let's say how the rest of the world
recites it well then obviously majority
consensus and you know kind of Common
Sense would say okay well for let's say
the past 1400 years the majority the 85%
of people have been reciting it this way
for a reason and this 50% that just came
and saying that they do it a different
way that kind of just proves who has
truly been preserving their text oh you
good who's that kind of reveals who's
truly preserving the text and who isn't
who's fabricating it but how how do you
know that that majority is doing it
correctly
well because they're all reciting at the
same way okay so like let me all right
some let me show you do you know who uh
IB Mas is no okay so I Mass he's one of
the companions of Muhammad and so he's
he's here's something that's special
about him Muhammad when he said you need
to learn the Quran learn it from these
four people what you're talking about
yeah yeah I've heard that one before
yeah good good so IB Mas was one of them
um if I'm not mistaken Umar binab was
another if I'm not mistaken I'll have to
double check though but but IB M he was
one of those special people that mamed
said hey this guy he learn the Quran
from him right okay so there's uh do you
have a Quran in your phone yeah okay go
to chapter 92 verse 3 chapter
92 chapter 2 verse three okay so what
does it say for you that wrong uh wrong
chapter come on
man on let me see it says and by the one
who created male and female by the one
who created male and female okay all
right so by the one who created male and
female good all right so this is sahkari
49 what ises that oh
cool let me actually go to the
website all right here we go so s bukari
4944 okay keep yeah let's keep that open
let's keep that open so it says narrated
Ibrahim the companions of Abdullah Bin
Mas came to Abu
dardam um and before they arrived at his
home he looked for them and found them
then he asked them who among you can
recite the Quran as Abdullah recites it
talking about Mas they replied all of us
so these are people who follow his
recitation right um he asked who among
you knows it by heart they pointed at Al
then he asked Al how did you hear
Abdullah Bin Mas reciting Surah Al the
night I'll come and recite it so that's
chapter 92
ver3 by the male and the
female Abu dard said I testify that I
heard me the prophet or that's look the
Tex I heard the prophet reciting it
likewise but these people want me to
recite it and by him who created male
and female but by Allah I will not
follow them right so IB M didn't recite
it like this how even majority of the
Muslim world has it recited mud and them
and even this guy abarda they recited it
by the male and the female not by him
who created the male and female or by
the one who created the male and female
so that's out mhm so then how would you
know then that which is is is correct
because if if majority is reciting it
this way but IM and his followers we
reciting it another way and Muhammad
pointed to him and said you need to
learn from him how do we then reconcile
this you know with this type of
different oral transmission mhm you know
so what I'm saying is that I I get that
majority can have like I guess that
influence you would think okay if the
majority is doing it this way then
they're they're with the tradition they
kept it going but when we go deeper into
it before this majority that we've seen
that's not how they recited it they're
reciting it differently MH yeah and
obviously I haven't there's not just
thousands but tens of thousands of
hadiths right and so I hav I read
probably a couple hundred already
definitely yeah only in a year yeah that
that's pretty solid but um what's it
called I mean I could do better trust me
but um what's it called I obviously
haven't read all of them right that
would take forever and also to like
study and really grasp what the meaning
is behind it but I can guar um I will
look into this I'll I'll tell you uh
what answer I can come up with yeah um
because um cuz obviously yeah like it's
it's it's um I want to I want to read it
and also I want to read it in the Arabic
I only know a little bit of Arabic um so
I'm trying to learn by the end of this
year I'm trying to you want to
understand the source abely understand
um I have no issue with you know getting
back to you as soon as I can I'm just I
just wanted to show you this I mean I'm
openminded so I'm not I'm not going to
close off and be like God bless you bro
yeah so yeah so that's I'm just you know
the point of this is to is to highlight
remember because I'm I'm talking about
what convicts you right that Islam is
the truth and so with working with your
framework it's about the preservation of
the Quran either textually or un orally
if there's textual variance if there's
textu that's that's fine cuz there's
oral transmission well if there's
variance in the oral transmission then
can you still have faith in the Quran as
as the same way that you do and so
that's just something to think about no
yeah absolutely I mean again I I don't
have the answer at the top of my head
for this question so I would love to
look into it and get back to you as soon
as I can um whether it's an answer that
I like or don't you know like I said
again I'm not going to lie to myself
right so uh I'm willing to do that so
what else is there um when it comes to
why I believe in this
um there's a lot I just don't know if
some of the reason okay for
example I think the theology makes the
most sense the theology theology
theology yeah so obviously I had a issue
at the end of my Orthodox walk as
Orthodox Christian with the Theology of
Christianity right specifically Orthodox
Christianity cuz I'm not sure if you
looked into it you know about Orthodoxy
or I'm looking into myself so it gets
deep it gets deep you can you can you
you'll spir out of control when you look
into it especially the theology itself
so but I guess to stick to Islam yeah
that would be one of my uh my biggest
points is the theology itself um what
what was it about the the Theology of
Christianity cuz I already asked you
about Islam I don't mind talking about
Christianity what was it that um you
were like yeah no this this doesn't make
any sense this isn't logical this isn't
even trying
I would say one of the biggest things is
trying to understand the hypothetic
union that's that's I mean look at
Eastern Orthodox right the easn Orthodox
Christians believe in diosi ISM right
they believe in what diosi ISM what is
that so in Eastern Orthodox so Eastern
Orthodoxy is different from Oriental
Orthodoxy they're both Orthodox but
Eastern Orthodoxy for example this is
the reason that they split they split
during the fourth ecumenical council so
Eastern Orthodox Christians believe that
Jesus is made of one nature uh I'm sorry
two Natures of divine and human mhm and
that makes up his two Natures the
Oriental Orthodox Christians believe
that Jesus is made of one nature but
that one nature consists of uh human and
divine so in a way yeah there's been a
very long debate of are they saying the
same thing or not and both sides say
we're not some of sometimes they'll say
we are but you know there was a language
barrier between us okay but um at the
end of the day um trying to understand
the person of Christ to me is very
difficult and it's also very important
though because obviously this this comes
down to very deep theology right like
what happened on the cross right so who
died what part of Jesus died you know
did Jesus die at all did he feel any
pain this and that it gets very deep and
so for example for me um trying to
understand the Divinity of Christ was
something that just I can never ever
wrap my head around the more I try to
understand it the more confused I left
and I noticed that the more I try to
convince somebody else that this was
true the more confused there would be
too and
um uh yeah I don't know if you really
want me to like kind of have the same
conversation with me me and him because
we kind of already had that long
conversation y'all did the hypothetic
Union a little bit yeah a little bit oh
not not not as deep as we are right now
but for example that itself so like I
don't know I guess what would you tell
me what happened on the cross to Jesus I
I hold the view that that he has two
Natures so I don't I don't believe that
he he had one nature that's mixed in
with Divine and human I I I I I don't
hold that at all but yeah that he had
two these are two Natures that are
united in the person of Christ and so if
you're talking about what happens on the
cross the pain he suffering crying out
my God my God why have you forsaken me
to the father I believe that that is um
him um taking on the suffering the grief
um the despair uh that comes with the
sin that he's carrying of the world
right and he's truly feeling that but
and and as he's truly feeling that he
dies all according to his flesh
obviously the divine nature can't cease
it can't stop it can't you know become a
corpse it doesn't have a body you know
so it's it's he dies pertaining to his
human nature um feels that despair that
anguish the pain you know physical pain
according to his human
nature so okay um obviously I've I've
heard different answers before right
especially in Orthodoxy okay um
but um I would say
another I'm trying to think I'm trying
to like have a different conversation
from what me and had because we had a
very similar conversation for
like oh yeah we can talk about that okay
okay okay cool so then previous
scriptures and stuff like that all right
so then as as so as a so as a Muslim now
do you hold the view that the Bible's
like uh corrupted changed distorted and
untrustworthy yeah not all of it but not
all of it a big portion of it okay so so
this is where the um the Dilemma comes
in that we usually bring up with the
Muslims is because and I don't know how
much of my stuff you've seen But I bring
this up all the time pretty sure I know
what you're going to say right now about
how the Quran talks about go to the inil
and the Torah yeah okay so I mean I'm
pretty sure maybe you've heard this
answer a lot of times but I guess I'd
like to hear your answer to it too as
well that the fact that obviously inil
doesn't mean Bible it means gospel right
on top of that the same way that we
believe that the oral tradition was
revealed to the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon Him is the same way that we
believe that the inil was revealed to
the prophet Jesus through oral
transmission not a book like a book
didn't come down from heaven or he
didn't write anything down and he
claimed this is theel we believe that
the in and the Torah was revealed to the
prophets through our tradition they
spread the inil they spread the Torah
but it's not written down anywhere for
us to look at and say okay you know this
is that this is all right so go and open
up chapter 7 verse 157 in the Quran
chapter 7 we get in the verse we getting
the verse chapter 7 verse 157
man
okay they are the ones who follow the
messenger the UN the unlettered prophet
whose description they find in their
Torah and gospel He commands them to do
good and forbid them from evil permits
for them what is unlawful and forbids
them forbids to them what is impure and
relieves them from their burdens and on
the shackles that bound them only those
got the same map yeah is this the right
this the one you that's the right verse
only those who believe in him honor and
support him and follow the light sent
down to him will be successful good now
I want there's the reason why I brought
you there specifically is because you
see where where it says that his
description is found in there yeah well
the word actually in the Arabic is m
tubin which means written and so let me
just show you that really quick so that
you can see what I'm saying um let's go
to I'm going to go to the to the
Lexicon and uh show you what I'm talking
about
Corpus
Quan come on
man all
right word for word all right I like
this one cuz it breaks down the Arabic
word word I love it all right so chapter
7 verse
157 all
right
okay so see how it breaks it down uh
word for word when we get to the word
mckuin it's written yeah all right I
have no problem with description as long
as they understand that it's a it's
written in there his description is
written in there in jail so I don't know
if you ever heard like the the saying
like it's written it's already written
like let's say your destiny is written
this and that you know what I mean
Muslims say that a lot and so when we
say that we don't believe that it's
literally written on a piece of paper we
believe that it's the Creed you know
what I mean no but they do because it
says that they have it with them so what
whatever they have they have it written
with them okay so even then though like
if you have something with you let's say
it doesn't have to be something physical
but it is if it's written again but we
have that that um what's the
word when Muslims say things like you
know let's say my destiny is already is
already written well okay I have my
destiny with me but my destiny is not
like a book in my hand your is not with
you that's your destiny is just
something that's decreed it's not
something you possess but you can say
that Destiny is like within me because
you every person has their own destiny
everyone has their own let's say plan
right but if you say like oh I have my
plan with me that's already written well
it's not like an actual journal or a
planner that's written physically in my
hand is something that's already
declared something that's with me not
physically but is already prepared for
me that's not that's I I hear what
you're saying but that's not how the
Quran describes any of this or anybody
puts this in this perspective when there
when it says here that they have the
Torah and the gospel with them these are
books that they have in the seventh
century and it says that they're written
and is that Muhammad's you know the
scription is written in their books
that's with them
so like there there's nothing wrong with
saying like for example what you said
that oral these were oral Revelations
right and that was passed down but
eventually they got written down they
were in book form MH you know and so I I
don't I mean everybody that I've seen
understood it understood it that way
yeah I mean that's fine I mean I asked
like let's say my Imam to see if he
holds this view as well if uh if he
agrees that like most people hold the
view and to see what both sides have to
say you know what I mean I'm more than
happy to get back on you on that yeah um
uh in my opinion though like just on all
honesty I don't really see it too much
as of an issue but again I'll get back
to you I have no issue with that so let
let me show you why okay so with with
the Torah and the inil being
written and the Jews and the Christians
they have it m and Muhammad's pointing
back to us saying hey I'm in your
scriptures I'm written in there right um
this would show that the Torah and the
gospel even from from the quran's point
of view that they have presently is is
true and is not corrupted or distorted
it's it's so it's true enough for them
to go into it and see that Muhammad's a
true Prophet you get what I'm saying
yeah yeah I've heard this before it's
just I guess my my like two things is
that I still have the issue of like
believing that this is really what it
means and that that's how it's you know
been believed to uh to been to be
interpreted yeah let's let's let's pull
up some tough here let's see what we get
so if we go to
rx.com
see some commentaries we can get on
this 157 have you heard of I yet yeah
okay good good we'll check him out see
what he
says all right let's go to tough Sears
here all right
let's
see all right so we'll look at a few so
here's Jal and these are the two
jalals um those who follow the messenger
the uninstructed prophet Muhammad whom
they will find inscribed in their Torah
and gospel in name and description and
joining them to decency and forbidding
them in decency and so on and so forth
so all right so so from jel Lan's point
it's he's physically inscribed in there
right he they have the Torah and the
gospel it's written down MH let's see um
K say anything let's see honestly don't
know who this guy is I don't that all
right let's see here those who follow
the another Prophet neither read nor
write this is I uh whom they find
written with them in the Torah and theil
this is the description of Prophet
Muhammad in the books of the prophets
they delivered the good news of his
Advent to their Nations and commanded
them to follow him his descriptions were
still apparent in their books as the
rabbis and Priests well known Imam Aid
recorded that Abu sakur something
something said that a ban man said to
him I brought I brought a milk producing
camel to al- Medina during the life of
Allah's messenger after I slda let's see
if this is relevant y y y I'm not sure
yeah it's not right yeah I think I think
what you oh oh here it is here it is
yeah so I passed by him while he was
walking between Abu Bakr and Umar and I
followed them until they went by a
Jewish man who was reading from an open
copy of the Torah he was mourning a son
of all right so anyway give giving the
Hadith and story of how they had an
actual physical copy uh yeah I think
that's that's fair um again like I said
I still want to just look at it from
different angles to see um cuz uh yeah
like obviously I'm not going to deny the
fact that two tough serers say that
there was U something inscribed right um
I don't I'm not a uh like tougher
knowledgeable scholar anything like that
right so I want to I want to see like
let's say things like on how trustworthy
they are how strong if they're like
upheld in the in the uh in the community
um and even if they are then yeah I have
no no issue with uh accepting that I
guess my my question to that would be I
have a TR have trouble believing
um the fact I guess I have trouble
believing it itself the fact that let's
say the Bible the New Testament uh
specifically is not uh not really
corrupted but that there wasn't some
type A there wasn't some type of um
what's the word uh what's the word is it
Distortion is it uh uh like when people
are trying
to like a different like a like a new
narrative like a different narrative um
because um I don't know if you watch a
lot of Alex oconor and stuff like like
that sometime so I'll listen to like B
man Conor um and I'll read sometimes
there articles about uh these topics
basically for example if you look at the
uh the New Testament if you look at the
uh four gospels right yeah what they
notice is that the Gospel of John is
actually obviously the oldest one the
oldest Gospel to be uh written and you
mean the latest right the latest exactly
yeah and so
there's a reason why we only see let's
say Jesus making these big claims they
argue they argue that John's gospel
develops more of a Divine Christ as
opposed to the earlier gospels and so I
was and I would argue against that I I
would argue that actually like for
example if they they say these liberal
Scholars they'll try to they'll say that
Mark's gospel is is early right and so
um and there they'll say that that that
you don't really see claims of Jesus in
Mark that's not true at all this is how
Mark starts
off so before we even get into that I I
guess I'm trying to make my point a
little more clear is the is the fact
that even Alex o Conor like admits this
he admits that the gospels and the
gospel authors are portraying Jesus to
be someone Divine but does Jesus himself
claim to be divine 100% okay I guess I
would like to know that you're well yeah
I'd like to say yeah of course okay so
um I'll I'll I'll just use Mark we we
won't John I'll use Mark okay so Jesus
himself claiming that he's divine right
now we got examples like for example we
know some attributes of God he's Eternal
all knowing um he's the one who forgives
sins
um uh he created the Sabbath right he
rules the Sabbath Day stuff like that
okay so this is where let's see what
Jesus makes a claim of go Mark chapter 2
so this is where Jesus heals the
paralytic man right and they drop him
from the roof yeah
um so we'll start at verse four and when
they could not get near him because of
the crowd they removed the roof above
him and when they had made an opening
they let down the bed on which the
paralytic lay and when Jesus saw their
faith he said to the paralytic son your
sins are forgiven
mhm now some of the sitting there
questioning their hearts why does this
man speak like that he is blaspheming
who can forgive sins but God alone and
immediately Jesus perceiving in his
spirit that they thus questioned within
themselves said to them now let's talk
about two things one he's forgiven sins
and then two he's ALS he also knows
their hearts what they're
thinking this isn't a mere creature now
uh this isn't somebody who thinks that
they're just a good Prophet cuz even in
the Bible it says that it's only God
that knows the hearts of man no one
reads the hearts of men except God alone
so I guess just to touch up on those two
already I guess how do you feel I guess
when Jesus gives authority to the
apostles to forgive sins as well it's
showing this will show that he's his his
divine nature why is that cuz how is he
able to give authority to forgive sins
he was given Authority by God the Father
it doesn't say that though so where does
he get the authority from he has it is
that was that what he says with So
within his nature yeah he says that the
son of man has authority to forgive sins
does he say that himself yeah yeah look
um where's it at here it is um why do
you question these things in your hearts
which is easier to say to the paralytic
your sins are forgiven or to say rise
take up your bed and walk but that you
may know that the son of man has
Authority on Earth to forgive sins he
said to the paralytic I say to you rise
pick up your bed and and go home yeah so
this verse uh I remember this one let me
see yeah so
I think it was Alex OK Conor as well who
gave commentary about this one where he
says something that kind of interested
me where he says which is easier to say
this to the paralytic and obviously he
says um you know it's kind of common
sense you know you're paralyzed you're
not going to just get up and walk so
what's what's easier to say that your
sins are forgiven um again I don't
really see the attribute to that uh
forgiving sins well again if we believe
that well yeah
forgiven sins only God could do that so
what happens during like a what happens
during the uh 12 Apostles when they
forgive sins as well again so he says
whatever they bind on Earth it will be
bound in heaven so it's being done
through Jesus Christ it's by his
authority that they're forgiving that
they're forgiving sins or sins are being
forgiven but even the authority that he
has like where is the connection between
him and God the father in that well is
remember he as he says the son of man
has auth himself he this author but that
you may know that the son of man has
Authority on Earth to forgive sins so
Authority on Earth to forgive sins yeah
he's here and he can forgive sins okay
this isn't this isn't something that he
says that God gave me this ability to do
or the father gave me this authority to
do this no he says the son of man has
this Authority yeah but at the same time
if he doesn't clarify where the
authority is coming from and if he
doesn't say so like what do you make of
that I really understand what you're
saying the authority is his it's not
that it's coming from the by virtue of
him being the son of man being God but
those two you're attributing though like
he doesn't really say that though like
all me being God's son or me being part
of God is the reason why I can forgive
he's saying him being the son of man
being the son of man he hasth so does
that mean that he is God absolutely so
when he says but that you may know that
the son of man that's already
attributing that he is God yes because
the the son of man is a Divine figure
this when he when he's claiming to be
the son of man look when he's claiming
to be the son of man the son of man is
watch uh so we'll go to Mark let's go to
14 like at at his crucifixion and then
I'll show you why this is important
being the son of man
okay it's blasphemy to even say
this yeah all right so look
um all
right but he remained silent and made no
answer again the high priest asked him
are you the Christ the son of the
blessed right and Jesus said I am and
you will see the son of man seated at
the right hand of power and coming with
the Clouds Of Heaven
MH and the high priest tore his garments
and said what further Witnesses do we
need you have heard this blasphemy what
is your decision now let me show you
yeah this they're not wrong that that
claim is Blasphemous if he's not telling
the truth yeah yeah right so but so
because he's telling the truth it's not
Blasphemous but if he's not he's a mere
man a mere Prophet making the claim to
be the son of man who is the son of the
Blessed who sits at the right hand of
the father on high and rides the clouds
these are Divine claims of Yahweh in the
Old Testament that's why they rip their
clo their robes cuz it's blasphemy he's
claiming to be God yeah and then can we
keep
keep um Taurus yeah uh what is your
decision and they all condemned him as
deserving death and some began to spit
on him and to cover his face and to
strike him saying to him prophesy and
the guards received him with
blows and so yeah when he says these
things right like that he seated at the
right hand of of uh of the father right
again that's it's blasphemy of course
because um in the Jewish tradition
there's obviously like no comparison in
let's say like a mere man to God right
even say being seated at the right hand
of him even if he's just a mere man not
even claiming to be God then saying
something like I'm being I'm going to be
seated you're going to see me seated at
the right you know right side of uh of
the father that's already like enough
for somebody to get killed absolutely
but exactly that's pretty much all he's
saying though he's not saying that's a
claim to Divinity isn't it if he if he's
claiming to sit at the right hand of the
of of the father so the father has his
throne and Jesus has a throne right next
to him well you're assuming that that
somehow makes him Divine though he's not
he's not claiming that himself though
he's not is going on here what do you
mean I mean you're saying like how's it
how's it BL what is blasphemy blasphemy
is it can be so many different things
yeah but what what is it what is it what
what comes to your mind when the the
term blasphemy is used what comes to
your mind honestly in the Christian
context it's it's it's two things one
it's pretty clear that like let's say
you're Mis
misusing uh like a theological view of
God and then two also I don't even know
because when the verse for example that
comes in and it says the blasphemy
against the holy spirit will not be
forgiven I mean you have a thousand
different answers of what that even
means you know what I mean so blasphemy
is very tricky in the in the Christian
context yes and so and that's a good
point you know in that context ascribing
devilish and satanic work to the Holy
Spirit that's blasphemy of the Holy
Spirit that's your answer yeah that's
that's what that's the context there
there there's Nuance I'm not saying that
like as a like as a way to like try to
like uh diminish your answer I'm just
saying cuz i' obviously there's answer
is all over the place right that's true
you you have different interpretations
there the Bible doesn't make it clear
I'm not saying that as an attack I'm
just saying like the Bible doesn't make
it clear and so it's a very confusing
text so would you agree that that
according to the Bible claiming to be
God as a creature is Blasphemous yeah
would be so if you're claiming that you
are equal with with God or on his level
in any way that's blasphemous right
right these and when you do that these
will be divine claims if you're if you
claim to sit next to the next to God
rule next to God sit on the throne next
to God and receive the same worship and
honor or whatever I would say yeah
that's that's blasphemy because
obviously you're putting yourself at
let's say I mean just saying that you
sit next to God himself and and you're
at his his right side of the throne
that's already Blasphemous itself but
again that I don't see the link between
aren't those claims of divinity no I
don't see that at all okay all right
so if he doesn't say it then I'm not
going to believe it you so so for you
it's hey guys I'm divine he has to say
it in those words in order for you to
say that he's claiming to be divine he
has to at least say that or say
something that's that's extremely clear
to him being God I mean again I've seen
like that's that's that's where I'm
confused at because if you're if you're
going to hold Jesus to these exact words
you have to say these words verbatim or
else you didn't make these claims if I
say for example I have students and I
give them lessons what did I claim to be
a teacher right but I didn't have to I
didn't Clearly say hey guys I'm a
teacher or hey guys I teach these I
think there's a huge difference between
someone like a mere man com uh claiming
to be a teacher versus somebody claiming
to be God and on top of that making it
extremely confusing for the reader to
even understand who he even is you know
what I mean cuz we we're going we're
going through this right now and I
understand what you're trying to say
right like I completely understand and I
agree the fact that let's say somebody
anybody claiming to be seated at the
right hand of God's Throne is
Blasphemous why but because anybody
claiming to even be like next to God in
heaven sitting on the throne next to him
is is you know so there those are Divine
claims aren't they I don't see that as a
when you say Divine claims like what do
you mean like are you saying these are
these are statements that that he's
equal to him that he's yeah that he's
his divinity that that he's I don't see
that if okay so if so then it's not
blasphemy then what's Blasphemous about
saying hey guys I'm going to sit on the
throne and Rule with the father God on
high how is that Blasphemous I mean I
kind of just said that is the fact that
even claiming like okay first of all we
have to clar something that we we cannot
concept like we cannot grasp the concept
of God right like let's say at least the
father like it's pretty much impossible
to think and try to imagine who God of
the father even is or looks like right
it's kind of impossible do you believe
do you agree or not sure so for a man to
say something like I'm going to sit next
to the creator of the entire universe
that nobody knows who you know how this
this Creator looks like what exactly the
Creator even is when it comes to like
let's say his nature and stuff like that
for somebody to say I'm going to sit at
the right side of him yes like why like
who who does that like why would you do
that um that's that's disrespectful how
um how's it disrespectful because God is
sitting above his creation and obviously
at least for us right like we don't
believe that his creation comes near him
exactly so if a creature claims that
he's going to sit above Creation With
God is that not a Divine claim I don't
think so no so then why is it
disrespectful
I mean I I just shed explaining to you
right now see it's it's it's you're
you're you're you're saying that the
without you're saying it without saying
it you're acknowledging that this is
blasphemy claiming to to be above
creation and be on the same level as God
these are Divine claims but you won't
say that these are Divine claims for
some
reason I mean I just don't really see
the correlation I guess and and even
then right let's say even he is saying
this I guess this would be my next
question right like this is a genuine
question that I've always had is that if
Jesus really is God and he wants people
to know that he wants people to accept
him why did he make it almost like a
puzzle to figure that out he didn't he
didn't no again he made it very clear
when he claims to be the son of man who
forgives sins yeah that's the son of man
he doesn't say okay let me just let me
let me show you why again and I guess I
want to give you a couple examples after
that of what I mean as well I I'll show
you why why the son of man claiming to
be the son of man is actually a Divine
Clan this is where Jesus remember he
said I'm going to sit at the right hand
of the father riding on the Clouds Of
Heaven that's me mhm right and the the
priest tore his robes and called that
blasphemy to that he's claiming to be
the son of man all right let's show let
me show you where where this is actually
coming from okay so it's coming from The
Book of Daniel chapter
7 and
look so we'll start here first in verse
n as I
looked Thrones were placed so there's a
multi there's multiple Thrones that are
placed the Ancient of Days took his seat
so the Ancient of Days sits on one of
those Thrones right so there's a throne
that's empty Ancient of Days takes his
seat his clothing was white as snow and
the hair of his head like pure wool his
throne was fiery Flames its Wheels were
burning fire a stream of fire issued and
came out of out from before him and a
thousand thousands served him and 10
thousands times 10 thousand stood before
him the court sat in judgment and the
books were opened who do you think who
do you think the Ancient of Days was
uh I'm waiting for your answer I guess
it'll be the it'll be the father okay
it'll be the father we'll we'll see this
more clearly so he takes his seat beasts
are worshiping him and all this kind of
stuff all right we get to verse 13 I saw
in the night visions and behold with the
Clouds Of Heaven mhm there came one like
a son of man mhm and he came to the
Ancient of Days and was presented before
him and to him was given dominion and
glory and the kingdom
that all peoples Nations and languages
should serve him his Dominion is an
everlasting Dominion which shall not
pass away and his kingdom one that shall
not be destroyed okay that's who Jesus
is saying he is the son of man okay the
one who rules forever with the father
with the Ancient of Days those forever
yeah um his Dominion is an everlasting
Dominion so his Dominion is Everlasting
okay y he has a glory a glory and a
kingdom all people's everyone's going to
be serving him okay and that same
service is the service that we saw with
the Ancient of Days earlier Ancient of
Days um whoops what did I just do
Ancient of Days
uh what I just
do oh um thousand a thousand thousands
served him right and 10,000 stood before
him y y y same thing is said about the
son of man that all people's Nations and
languages should serve him his Dominion
Everlasting okay Kingdom one that won't
pass away or be destroyed mhm this is
who Jesus is saying he is okay right and
he says that he's the one that sits on
the throne with the father above the
Angels everyone serving and worshiping
them this is who Jesus is saying well
yeah because the service here the type
of service is given here the word is Pak
in the air man okay Pak is service
that's given to God yeah okay so I guess
there's a couple things for that so one
um when you just read that passage I
don't yeah okay let's say even if if I
grant this to you right that this is
Jesus who's claiming to let's say
fulfill this verse right this this this
these verses that you showed me MH I
guess I'm trying to see where the
Divinity between that is because again
well yeah I'm serious because if you're
going to tell me that what yes I mean
because the verses that you just gave me
I see it dominion and um people are
serving him this and that I mean again
that itself let's say just the word
alone serving I mean doesn't mean uh
Worship in the context that you worship
God right I mean you can serve your
manager you can serve your friend do who
do all nations peoples languages and
tongues who do they all serve do they
serve a man or a creature or do they all
serve god well actually I mean us as
Muslims we believe that we uh serve um
we serve God right but through that we
he also has his own servant Muhammad who
to this day every single person should
be uh serving you serve Muhammad not
serve in the context of let's say I'm
doing five prayers to him but I am
keeping his does Muhammad have dominion
over you and do you serve him as one who
has dominion over you Muhammad has as a
prophet authority over me to give things
like FAS to give me guidance in my life
as a human being like he was he's
telling you what God what God said this
is God Authority that he's communicating
with you not his own right I'm sorry
this is this is so Muhammad is
communicating to you God's Authority not
his own right yeah but Muhammad as a
prophet and also as the main Center of
Islam has an authority over mean all
Muslims in a way as to as to how to live
okay but are you serving him or how in
how you live or are you serving God in
how you live I'm serving God through the
uh through the teachings of M right so
not serving Muhammad you're serving God
yeah we're serving God here you're not
just serving the Ancient of Days you're
serving the son of man mhm that's the
difference yeah I can see what you're
saying um that's a difference brother I
mean yeah I can see what you're saying
but so how is this not
Divine I I mean I'm down to look into it
I'm done look into a little more again
um I've I've studied the New Testament
twice but read it twice the Old
Testament obviously it's a huge book and
I I've read books of it but I haven't
finished it but that verse ex I just
want to touch a little bit more on it I
mean these two comparisons
um when we when we when I asked you
earlier about if God or Jesus makes it
clear um even
then uh let's say I grant this to you
right that he is fulfilling this and
somehow this claims for him to be divine
yeah again I still don't see how makes
anything simple to understand because
again like I said earlier it's like you
has to put puzzles together and again
the same way that you showed me a new
testament verse and you ho all the way
back to a very old book in the Old
Testament to even put these two together
to even understand who God is is a very
complicated process to even understand
who God is if God is really trying to
make things simple yeah I hear what
you're saying Christian but you got put
put in this perspective as well in this
perspective look at who the audience is
it's a Jewish audience right yeah that's
right so if when he's talking to Jewish
people and it's a Jewish audience he's
going to speak to them they're going to
get it right obviously for us in the
21st century the ones who are not
familiar with the terms and the the
theology or whatever we we have to go
and look deeper well exactly that's kind
of my issue is that like if he made that
so easy for the group that he was
already around and then made it harder
for the rest of the billions of people
to come afterwards then we're the ones
that are suffering having to put all
these puzzles together putting New
Testament and Old Testament versus
together to even make sense of who God
even is brother that's that's not
something that is is making it hard for
us it's it's a it's it's called study if
if something is look if some if I look
at something and I don't understand what
it what it means necessarily I'm not
from that time you know I'm not part of
that culture so I don't know how
significant son of man is but Jesus is
clearly claiming to be the son of man I
see the the attributes that come with
being the son of man riding on the
Clouds Of Heaven ruling with the father
from for for forever and Eternity and
and I see that the these religious
leaders charge him for blasphemy for
saying such a thing that should charge
me to say hm why is being the son of man
so Blasphemous what the heck son of man
what does that mean and that charges
takes me to go look into that and I see
oh my gosh this is who the son of man is
he's claiming to be God clearly when I
study
yeah
so I guess that's just again like a very
okay let me ask you a question do you
believe that you only need the New
Testament to be saved that I only need
the New Testament I I believe that I
need Jesus to be saved not necessarily
New Testament before there was a new
testament exactly I mean the Jesus only
comes into the New Testament right no
he's in the Old Testament too okay I I
get what you're trying to say but I'm
I'm saying like his life and him
declaring you know who he is and this
and that and people you know referencing
him by name is that only in the New
Testament
no no no so we get Isaiah 53 that breaks
down ex right four The Fifth Gospel yeah
so you know all this stuff right no no I
understand that but I'm just saying like
Okay the point I'm trying to make is
that not really trick question but it's
just like a point that I'm trying to
make clear is that for example when I
was my last job I uh met a woman who
told me cuz I was Orthodox Christian at
that time right and I told her that I
was Orthodox Christian and she told me
that her daughter recently got her hands
on the Bible and she started reading it
and she was reading the New Testament
specifically she started with the
gospels and she would go to her mom
after reading it every single time and
say Mom I just don't get it I just don't
get it it's just so so confusing and I
remember at the time it would like it
would have scared me so much because I'm
like oh my goodness bro like why is it
so why is it always that when people try
to look into the Bible and read it and
understand it they they always come out
confused and I actually started getting
scared that she was going to leave the
faith because of that I'm not sure what
of happening with her but this is just
kind of my point is that if you only
read the New Testament itself and you
don't read the Old Testament you don't
have that context then you really aren't
going to be able to put you know pieces
together
to understand let's say what you tried
to show me because you have to put two
and two together you have to read the
Old Testament and you have to go back to
these verses to put this verse together
and then connect it to make something
make sense you know what I mean it's
very difficult it's very complicated so
if a Christian were to let's say read a
new testament and that's it for the rest
of the life they never even knew about
the Old Testament right would they even
be saved would they even understand who
Jesus is who is trying to portray let me
let me respond to that so one to be
saved all we need is the gospel of Jesus
that's all we need right um believing in
the gospel who he is and um the
Revelation that he brought before there
was a new testament there was just
simply the gospel right and then
obviously Old Testament scripture to
back to go off of so you don't need a
new testament to read it in order to be
saved I can be on my deathbed without
ever having read the New Testament have
the gospel presented to me and believe
you know but hold on so but if I wanted
to I can just show you straight from the
New Testament alone that Jesus is divine
like I only did that to to to highlight
cuz you didn't know what son of man was
I I did well I mean I I kind of do
because I mean you also see like
different people being called that as
well right so like you see like who is
it David being called the son of man as
well yeah a I think it's Ezekiel
actually e called a son of I me that's
kind of what I mean it's like but
there's there's a difference between a
son of man in a general sense meaning
Humanity and the son of man who is
prophesied and I'm gonna try to get back
to you as soon as I can with which verse
I'm thinking about but I I swear I
remember I can probably help what do you
think what you talking about I think it
was David something about like God
calling David the son of man or him
calling himself the son of man but not
in the way where he's just talking about
his father like being a son of a father
you know what I mean yeah no that's I
swear somebody else it's not David but
it's it's it's Ezekiel so like I guess
what's your answer to like what's the
correlation there like if if he's not
talking about himself as a son of man in
the context of being the son of of a of
a mere human there is there is no there
is no verse where anyone else is
identified as a son of man in the sense
where it's not you know just as as human
when it comes to Jesus he refers to
himself as that son of man in Daniel
7even who rise the Clouds Of Heaven who
rule sits at the right hand of of the
Majesty on high okay okay as soon as I
can I'll get back to you on that but
also I guess that's kind of the point
that I was trying to make I know you
said you were trying to highlight that
for me but again even if we didn't have
the Old Testament and we didn't have any
knowledge about it because at the end of
the day Christians always say that
really all you need is Jesus right where
does Jesus come in at least like boldly
and clear and you know clarify things in
the New Testament so if we didn't even
have the new the Old Testament right now
in a way you wouldn't be able to puzzle
these things together and prove uh what
you're trying to prove because I mean
what's wrong what's wrong I so I don't
understand what what the problem is cuz
if we're if I have I guess my issue if I
have the old if I have the Old Testament
the old Covenant that points to the
Fulfillment which is Jesus in the new
Testament and I have both I have the
full picture what's the problem gu I
guess that word itself fulfillment like
when he says that I came to not to a
boster law but to fulfill it I mean
again there's a pretty big distinguish
distinguish be between um abolishing the
law and fulfilling it and when he comes
in and he says that and I don't see him
doing things like uh not getting rid of
the Old Testament laws that the Jews
were practicing but Christians doing
that now you know where's the uh where's
the correlation between those two I
guess is my question with what exactly
so like for example so we're moving from
Jesus claiming Divinity no we can we can
stay on that um for example uh like I
said I'll get back to you on the whole
son of man uh topic because I forgot
which one it was I don't know if it was
David or maybe Ezekiel like you said but
I swear I remember somebody else being
called the son of man I remember son of
man okay yeah again just so we don't
lose time I'll look to it myself on my
own time so I can understand the context
of it and give back to you as as soon as
I can um but okay also for the Divinity
of Christ
um these uh I'm I'm guessing you're
going to quote other verses like when
Jesus says I am right no St
Mark is Mark that's in John is it huh
that's in John where he says before
Abraham was I am oh that was only in
John yeah that's in John okay I thought
that was in more yeah I I I'll I I want
to show the verses about you know cuz
their their argument Alex okon Bart man
that this stuff developed that in Mark's
gospel in the earlier gospels you don't
have Jesus making Divine claims and
that's what I'm against yeah okay yeah I
guess you word it correctly because I
guess like what I see and also what like
Alex Conor bman like kind of itate is
the fact that like they'll admit that
the the gospel authors are portraying
this narrative that Jesus is divine but
like the the the Dilemma is Jesus affirm
that you know what I mean yeah and I
guess I don't really see and and
sometimes I see that right I'll I'll
I'll grant that sometimes I see that and
sometimes I see the opposite and so
that's the part where the the Dilemma
comes in for me because it's like okay
um you know let's say what's another one
like if you can throw me another Jesus
claiming to be divine uh he says that
he's the lord of the Sabbath The Lord of
the Sabbath okay so let's
say that verse right and then I'll read
the verse where he
says um
where he
says uh oh yeah that um pretty sure you
heard this one before I'm trying to
think of
it bet you was going to be in John no it
probably won't be in John no uh because
I was actually doing like my studies in
in the three gospels itself too what's
the name of it again for like the fourel
theop but not not including John
um what happened I'm just I'm waiting I
know I'm trying to I'm trying to
memorize the actual like quation
paraphrase I can prob okay when he says
um when he says uh the hour is not
known Nobody Knows the no knows the Not
Angels the the father alone yeah I guess
that's kind of like okay oh I'm sorry it
was that one and it was this one finally
finally clicked the one where he where
he doesn't know if the if the tree is in
season but it doesn't say he doesn't
know if the Fig is in season it doesn't
no okay can we pull up just a refresh my
mind I'm not going to try to you know
make a claim that I that I'm getting
wrong okay yeah so it's basically this
is the verse let me try to get the verse
exactly though I'm not trying to just
read off
quotations I think it's Mar yeah Mark
it's Mark 111 12- 14 I believe yeah all
right so on the following day when they
came to Beth Bethany he was hungry and
seeing in the distance a fig tree in
leaf now this is important mhm that the
Fig Tree is in leaf he went to see if he
could find anything on it when he came
to it he found nothing but leaves for it
was not the season for figs and he said
to it may no one ever eat fruit from you
again and his disciples heard it right
um and they came to Jerusalem he went
into the temple and that's when he
cleared out the temple and all that kind
of good stuff all right
so one here's a detail that we need to
know that the Fig Tree was in leaf now
what's the point of mentioning that
because when fig trees bear their leaves
that shows that they are in an early
season to Bear what is called braver
fruit so they have early fruit even
before they're in the season of
figs right and so so if the Fig Tree is
showing Leaf then it has it's supposed
to have some early fruit it didn't but
it had the appearance that it did um and
notice he does this in front of his
disciples this is all important because
if you go on he's talks about how he's
cleansing the temple and all this kind
of stuff dealing with the Pharisees
later on right this is all an
illustration of of Israel and the
Pharisees because they're dressed up
with the appearance that they bear fruit
with the appearance of godliness but
really they bear no fruit and they are
cursed and that's what the illustration
of the Fig Tree
is okay okay so it's not that he didn't
know you know that it wasn't in season
or stuff yeah and yeah and and the the
verse yeah obviously it doesn't say that
he didn't know right I guess it's just
like it doesn't make sense for you to go
up to a tree and hoping for something to
be there and then it's not there you
know what I mean sorry just give me one
second all right okay um yeah so
obviously I don't I don't think and I
don't claim either that the the verse is
quoting quoting it saying that he
doesn't know right but I guess it's just
again like who goes up to approach tree
um and curses it without you know having
this like reaction to it doesn't have
something that I wanted you know what I
mean does it does it does it make sense
in light of the entire context and the
illustration in a in a way in a way it
does in a way I'll get I'll give that in
a way does I still have like my iffy
feeling about it but I can see your
point um so yeah it's just again I think
I think that's kind of just like my main
point right is that I grant Christians
the um the person perspective of like
okay like I see Divine claims from Jesus
or I see Divine claims from the authors
of the gospels right but then I can also
see Christians when they say well no
like Jesus isn't claiming or like yeah
Christians say Christians that say you
know Jesus isn't claiming Divinity or no
such thing as a Christian who says that
okay well there someone is saying that
they're not Christian well yeah by by
definition they're not right but let's
say followers of Christ who believe in
the Bible they're still not followers of
Christ well they they can they claim
they can let's say people that claim
that they follow
Christ who read the Bible and they call
themselves followers of Christ at least
right because that's like the unorthodox
definition but I can see both sides
that's the point I'm trying to make and
I think even Alex OKC Conor says that
too is that he grants both sides he can
see a side of Christians that say Jesus
is claiming to be divine and then the
side where they don't see that or at
least they believe that you know the
Christians who are claiming these things
about Jesus being Divine are doing a
stretch well I I I think it's impossible
to be honest with the text and say that
Jesus is not claiming to be divine when
you see stuff like what we just saw like
the son of man thing or him him claiming
to exists before Abraham was him
claiming to be the one who gives eternal
life him claiming to be the one who
judges at the day of on the day of
judgment who's the dead is going to hear
rise at his voice um claiming to be the
first and the last the Alpha and Omega
these are all things that Jesus says
about himself bro it was a dope
conversation man with my friend my new
friend Christian um you know I hope that
you guys can see that we can have these
conversations man we're we're sitting in
at Carl Jr you know just kicking and
chilling um talk about our disagreements
getting clarification and stuff as you
guys can see man the dude is open-minded
he's listening um giving his arguments
as well and like we're discussing it so
I hope that you guys can appreciate this
man if you wanted to say something to
the bo bro that's pretty much it the
same thing you know we had a good
conversation we'll probably have another
one pretty soon God willing so you know
that's pretty much that yeah we don't
always have to be fighting each other
you know what I mean y 100% all right
y'all stay tuned on the next video man